everybody's Gary Vaynerchuk and we want
to talk about the word social medias
many of you guys have heard me say
before you know it was called web 2.0
last year it's gonna be called median
next year and I was giving a lot of
thought you can pop the champagne camera
okay um make a loud sound um I was gonna
get a lot of thought and I've been
talking to a lot of brand managers and
ad people and I've realized the word
social media is really hurting people in
the traditional space people that are
very brilliant have been amazing at
creating and executing media for a long
time but what's happening is the word is
social media and they really still
believe that they control the message
that we've got to come up with creative
and then through social media we're
gonna put it out there we're gonna sell
it we're gonna force it down the throats
of the consumer because that's always
been the game's my friend that's been
the game and so that word media I think
has really hurt besides the fact that
people are making personal decisions
don't want it to succeed from making
decisions financially from themselves
and are worried about their understudies
there's another reason it's not totally
being adopted as quickly as it could and
that's because the word media is
screwing this whole thing up because
what social media really is is customer
service it's really getting in the
trenches and caring and so if the word
was social service though I know that
gets weird and these aren't thinking
about different things or social caring
which doesn't really make sense
but I know the word media is strong
everybody for a loop because the way we
always did media before was we
controlled the story we came up with the
story and we sold it this whole game is
backwards you listen to the consumer
it's more like running a retail store it
wasn't really about the ads that brought
them in the store it's once they're in
the store what do you do with them the
players are now in play my friends
they're all there you don't need to sell
them on being on Twitter or Facebook or
engaging with your brand that's already
happening it's what you do once you get
them in there you actually have to care
now you next have to work now you have
to get dirty now it's time to roll up
the sleeves now that's what's really
going on and so I think the word media
is throwing a lot of people off I don't
want to necessarily call it social
service but the fact of the matter is is
that the word media one last time is
throwing everybody for a car
ball and it's really the pin that I've
seen a lot of people in traditional
advertising struggle with guys you don't
control the game you're not gonna sell
them on anything it's how you engage
with them and that's the game